did you know that everything is made of
chemicals
and chemicals can react to form new
chemicals
on the tv show bill nye the science guy
helped many kids get interested in
science
in the 1990s now he's working to inspire
the next
generation of scientists with a new book
bill nye's great big
world of science which covers everything
from atoms to astrophysics and includes
dozens
of do-it-yourself experiments to try at
home he's going to try one for us in a
minute bill joins us from los angeles
good morning bill thanks for being with
us uh i want to warn you advancedly
good morning good morning i want to warn
you in advance they picked the guy who
flunked seventh grade science to lead
this segment
so this book is like perfect for me it's
about my speed
let me let me begin at the end because
one of the things you say to everybody
on your way out of this book is
it's really important to stay curious
how do you do that
how do you not people what's more
exciting than the world around us my
goodness
now everybody is curious just what we
want is everybody to be
at some level scientifically literate
so that we can make good decisions as a
society
uh because sciences was science is what
has enabled this amazing uh
video call here in the in the morning on
a monday
and so it's and science isn't a thing uh
that does stuff
humans do things scientists engineers
do things and the taxpayers and voters
that support the research
so a lot of a lot of kids obviously are
stuck at home right now
and and parents are looking for a way to
keep them gauged and curious as you're
talking about there you are
uh actually watching you get ready for
this segment was fascinating bill
but you have an experiment about ocean
currents
that we can that parents can do with
their kids right at home take us through
this
oh sure well this is so this is a
classic switch is
so we all depend on the ocean if you
you live in new york there about um
uh uh half at least half
of the air you breathe comes from the
ocean
more like in new york florida it's more
like two-thirds
a tablespoon of salt into a cup of water
i'm using english units just to
help you all out my goodness it's 35
parts per million so uh
anyways mix it up it is hard to believe
at first
but ocean water is has this much salt in
it
yeah that really does never swarm in the
ocean
yeah i know well it's not my it wasn't
my idea no so
anyway uh the ocean water you know when
i was a kid it wasn't clear how the
ocean
kept the same salinity but it turns out
it has to do with the hydrothermal vents
then uh uh beautiful blue food coloring
yeah
you don't need blue but we all associate
blue with the ocean
so a few drops stir it up now here's the
thing
we all depend on the ocean for our
oxygen we all depend on the ocean
uh for the food for much of the food we
eat either directly or indirectly
and the key to living things in the
ocean is circulation
the ocean has currents that are always
moving it's sort of essentially
fertilizes
the ecosystem right so how does what
causes the ocean to move around well a
lot of it is this nature of
salt uh and fresh water so here's a tray
of fresh water
we will bring the camera because in the
coved world we can just grab the camera
bring her on down and there we are and
uh
i pour the salt water down the straw
it's just the straw just helps guide it
into the uh brownie dish
or baking dish now if you look you can
see
the salt water stays at the bottom
wow it doesn't mix very fast i mean
it's just when you think about it you
mix in all that salt well i guess so
of course it would stay on the bottom of
course it would no but this has an
enormous effect on you and me because
this is
what enables us to breathe if you live
in the heartland if you live in nebraska
kansas oklahoma
about a third of the oxygen you breathe
comes from the sea
if you live in florida it's most of it
so uh what happens is the sun evaporates
the ocean surface and the salt remains
also in the book
is uh i let some of this water dry out
yesterday
and uh it leaves the salt and the blue
food coloring behind this
saucer by the way is from south africa
built
but it worked anyway i gotta interrupt
you bill the book is full of fascinating
stuff like that thank this is a
really interesting experiment thanks for
being with us bill nye's great big world
of science goes on sale tomorrow